[Music]  it's a news overload  tell everybody about at uh black lives  matter  rally in in 2k  let's see uh what  what marcus so this is this is this  [ __ ] in  they're playing the game around the  country yeah  but this is this is the park so that's  where you play with people  i everybody just went running through  yeah they're rude  i was gonna ask cause y'all play online  do people because i heard people say  racist stuff on call of duty do people  say stuff like that in in 2k  i i like that you brought that up  because that's the main reason like in  the early days of like all those  first-person shooters  i couldn't get into it because it would  just be little kids saying the craziest  [ __ ] they'd be like i'm coming after you  china man  like how i don't know how they know your  chinese  because my name my username was  chinaman346  my call next get out of here you monkey  [Applause]  it's a news overload media